Hello, and welcome to this video on Concepts.
In this, we are going to do an overview of the three primary components that are going to control the animation.
That is the Controller, the Pawn, and the Animation Blueprint.
Firstly, we have the Controller.
It's like a central command unit that steers the behaviour of Pawns.
Pawns are characters or objects within the game world.
Now, this can work by either interpreting the player input
or it could be controlled by an AI.
So the computer would control it using something like a behaviour tree.
Next, we have the Pawn, which is the physical representation of the character in the game.
It is vital for defining how a character moves and interacts with the game's physics.
Finally, we have the Animation Blueprint, which is a system for animating a skeletal mesh.
Within this, we have two main elements, the Event Graph and the Ami Graph.
The Event Graph plays a critical role by receiving data from other sources
and then processing that data so that it can be used to generate the animations.
This data will then be funneled into the Ami Graph.
The Ami Graph itself, short for Animation Graph,
is tasked with processing the incoming data to drive the animation,
ensuring that the character's movements are both fluid and accurate.
It can also use state machines and the control rig
to produce complicated animations that respond to the gameplay.
Together, these components work in tandem to bring the character to life,
providing a seamless and interactive player experience.
Understanding how they interlink is crucial for any developer
looking to set up a professional-looking game animation.
Let's go through the animation process step by step so that we can see how they connect.
So firstly, we have the Pawn, or character, which carries a skeletal mesh.
This mesh is the framework that defines the physical structure
and appearance of the character in the game world.
Secondly, the skeletal mesh is equipped to hold and execute the Animation Blueprint.
These Blueprints are pivotal in defining the character's movement and behavior.
Thirdly, the Animation Blueprint processes the Ami Graph's output.
The Ami Graph is the engine that calculates the character's animation state frame by frame,
based on the gameplay and the environmental interaction.
Finally, we have the Event Graph, and that collects and deciphers data for the Ami Graph.
It acts as a conduit, enabling the Animation Blueprint
to respond dynamically to real-time gameplay events.
This is all we are going to cover for Concepts.
We will be going over a lot of other elements,
however, this is best done in the context of an exercise.
This will allow us to see how everything fits together in context.
So our next video, we will be starting setting up for the exercise.